Today we return to the street to see if their faces
have become better known to us.
Can you tell me who these people who appear are?
here?
I know them,
but I don't know the name,
not right now,
with all the shame in the world,
no,
of all, no,
but this example is,
and now neither are they.
Besides, I don't watch TV,
so if you don't watch TV,
You still don't know which are the last ones,
eh,
Conquis finalists.
Ah, okay,
no good. Well, no,
not really.
What do you say?
Yes, no,
things are political,
no, what a VA,
is 1 1 pint,
politicians,
not politicians. Political.
Specifically,
we could tune in 1 little more.
Yes,
they are for conservative government elections.
This one does not belong to the PNV,
this one is from Pepe del Pepe.
Well, look,
it had turned out so well.
This one belongs to the PNV.
I know it is Santurce's,
I think, ha, ha.
I saw it just yesterday on the news,
I saw it by chance,
but no,
I couldn't tell you the name,
huh?
Ah, uh,
pradradales or something.
No,
pradales or something like that.
s,
yes,
pradanes,
radales,
radales.
This is the p9,
no,
that's from the PSOE too,
JP, come on,
I guess she is a PSOE mayor.
Lately I've been doing a little bit of
eh, andueza.
Dachi VA this way,
you know,
already knows Neko andueza,
is this HD or what?
No, that's from Vox.
That's right.
We don't give 1, huh? Fuck,
this one is from h Bildu,
isn't it?
It can be
chúpame cari,
what is the name of Bildu's?
and Andoni no?
Skin, fur,
so candlestick.
Ah, that one,
of course,
we are very embarrassed.
That's for sure.
In other words,
we have concerns.
But well,
you caught us in 1 moment 1 little bit.
bad,
are they new people?
I don't think people know people today,
today, in every way,
there is a lot of information about
and this girl so young,
so beautiful
not to add,
or can we?
Well, I just don't know,
no,
not the same on the other side,
yes,
not of citizens,
man, no,
No,
citizens are no longer there,
they are not, okay?
Ah,
yeah,
look,
uh,
chubby hat,
come here cap,
ha, ha, ha.
Gorrochategui,
gorrochategui,
ah, gorrochategui,
great,
Look how the pastry chef of we can.
Well, then,
as I said,
Don't you think that people in general
Do you know which candidates are for the elections?
Huh?
At 175% I think so,
no,
1 little fifty there is 1 little bit of everything,
not because there are many new faces,
you more or less know where the air hits us,
not when you vote that you vote more for the person,
for the game,
what do you care more man,
if I don't really know them,
in the end you still go for 1
for 1 game.
The match offers things,
but it is the candidate who transmits.
People vote, so that,
by inertia as well,
but well, out of habit,
just like the parents.